[Musica]
Buongiorno Buongiorno a tutti e mi
piacerebbe oggi insieme a voi fare
qualche riflessione sull'energia e poi
qualche riflessione sull'impatto che ha
l'energia nella mobilità per noi diciamo
un elemento che vediamo tutti i giorni
insomma quindi
l'energia
per noi uomini è un concetto
estremamente ampio lo conosciamo come
concetto fisico lo conosciamo anche un
pochettino come concetto empatico
diciamo delle persone hanno una buona
energia Diciamo che un posto è pieno di
energia e poi conosciamo anche l'energia
proprio quella che ci serve in casa per
utilizzarli elettrodomestici per
spostarci e in questo momento più ancora
che in altri momenti diventa un elemento
di cui vale la pena di riflettere e di
pensare
l'energia vista da sola è un concetto
molto importante Ma l'energia insieme
alle informazioni è un concetto che
ancora più importante se pensiamo
qualsiasi Progresso umano è legato
principalmente alla migliorata capacità
dell'utilizzo dell'energia Quindi
abbiamo imparato a cuocere diciamo le
carni abbiamo imparato
valorizzare in maniera migliore
l'energia abbiamo imparato a scaldarci
Quindi la nostra vita è sempre legata
all'energia ed è stata sempre di più
legata all'energia
Einstein che è stato un grande pensatore
e non solo scientifico ma anche con
grandissimi pensieri
dal punto di vista sociale ha detto che
tutto è energia e questo è tutto quello
che esiste quindi l'energia è davvero
l'energia per come la pensiamo l'energia
per come la utilizziamo l'energia per
come la viviamo è veramente un pilastro
importantissimo dell'evoluzione
dell'uomo
Carlo Rubbia premio nobel nel 1984
studiando un semplice
particella di massa
sostanzialmente scoperto che nella
particella di massa ci sono nucleoni e
fotoni Cioè ci sono Massa ed energia e
la quantità di energia rispetto alla
quantità di massa e circa un miliardo di
volte più ampia quindi effettivamente
anche la fisica ci dice quanto è
importante l'energia E
sostanzialmente mi piace questo
parallelo anche le persone che pensano
in maniera meno scientifica hanno un
concetto Se vogliamo di distacco dalla
massa è più vicino all'energia Alda
Merini dice che prendere le distanze
della materia è un segno di grande
saggezza se vogliamo è sicuramente anche
questa una concezione di energia un
tentativo di dire Guardate che l'energia
è più importante della massa è
importante a mio avviso questa
riflessione perché davvero l'energia è
un concetto che ci accompagna nella
nostra vita forse
conosciamo poco ne conosciamo gli
effetti ma conosciamo poco la mia vita
Soprattutto negli ultimi anni
diciamo è stata più orientata
all'utilizzo dell'energia nella mobilità
e quindi mi piacerebbe a questo punto
adesso che ci siamo fatti un'idea di
quello che è l'energia parlare un
pochettino di più di quello che è
l'energia Prima di tutto come abbiamo
detto prima tutto energia si misura con
energia
l'utilizzo paghiamo l'energia quella che
noi chiamiamo la bolletta elettrica di
fatto è un consumo di energia
anche anche ciò che mangiamo energia e
le due forme e le due unità di misura
kilowattora
diciamo i fisici e noi poveri ingegneri
e invece per i medici le kcal di fatto
sono sostanzialmente la stessa cosa
dicono sostanzialmente la stessa cosa
per avere un'idea un
anche la vita di tutti i giorni è
sostanzialmente
alimentata la nostra vita e alimentata
dall'energia è importante sapere quanto
vale l'energia quindi noi utilizziamo
l'auto tutti quanti parleremo
inizialmente di auto a benzina e quindi
ci piacerebbe sapere Quanta energia un
chilogrammo di benzina Perché tutto
sommato noi sappiamo che la nostra auto
fa 20 km con un litro ma non sappiamo
Quanta energia c'è
sostanzialmente in questo litro in
questo chilo il chilo forse è un
pochettino di più però insomma non
abbiamo questa idea Mi piacerebbe
partire un attimino vedendo anche dei
paragoni abbiamo detto prima che Tutta
energia forse non sappiamo neanche
Quanta energia ha un chilo di maionese
ma un chilo di maionese a circa 7,5 kW
di energia quindi a Caspita se pensiamo
che l'auto va a benzina e che la
copertina a 10 kilowatt di energia
Caspita
diciamo un un
chilogrammo di benzina a 10 kilowattora
la classica Allora la maionese molto
energetica Venezia Però al di là di
questo vediamo un attimino veniamo un
attimino a quello che è la nostra
chiacchierata di oggi abbiamo detto che
in un chilo di benzina vengono contenuti
circa 10 kW di energia e noi con questo
chilogrammo di benzina Facciamo 20 km
quindi questa è una cosa che sappiamo
non sapevamo o forse Alcuni di noi non
sapevano che aveva 10 kilowattora di
energia però sapevamo che facevamo 20 km
ci siamo sempre di più avvicinando
all'utilizzo di auto elettrica abbiamo
sentito cosa capiterà nel 2035 in parte
si sente parlare anche adesso di auto
elettriche e Insomma ci siamo chiesti
Mai quanto invece energia e contenuti in
un chilogrammo di batterie un kg di
batterie contiene circa 0,2 kilowattora
di energia vedete che la differenza è
incredibilmente grande quindi si
potrebbe addirittura pensare che
quando noi utilizziamo un altro a
benzina Riempiamo il serbatoio mettiamo
non so 40 litri 50 litri quello che ci
serve per nuovo di solito facciamo il
pieno non stiamo neanche vedere quello
che ci serve per muoverci Facciamo il
pieno ma di che cosa ci preoccupiamo di
quanto costa il contenuto il contenitore
un pezzo di plastica non ho mai
preoccupato nessuno
l'auto elettrica
sposta un pochettino il pensiero perché
nell'auto elettrica Il problema è quanta
batteria ha perché il costo sta nella
batteria perché il l'autonomia sta nella
batteria Quindi il problema si è
spostato aveva un problema di contenuto
e siamo immediatamente qui a parlare di
un problema di contenitore Quindi è già
una prima come posso dire un primo
pensiero un attimino diverso benissimo
quindi abbiamo un chilo di batteria
nella nostra auto elettrica abbiamo
visto che può contenere circa 0,2
kilowattora di energia quanta strada
possiamo fare con questo chilogrammo di
batteria Diciamo che possiamo fare circa
1,2 km quindi
sostanzialmente possiamo pensare uno se
ci fa piacere così diciamo un chilo di
batteria un chilometro voglio 400
chilometri da autonomia devo mettere 400
kg di batteria chiaramente questo ci fa
cominciare a pensare che questo è un
problema che l'energia diventa un
problema diventa un problema per noi
diciamo utenti quelli che alla fine la
utilizziamo Ma
se andiamo a vedere con questo diciamo
chilo di batterie con cui facciamo solo
1,2 km l'utilizzo dell'energia è
decisamente migliore perché facciamo
circa 0,15 kilowattora con un chilometro
mentre invece con l'energia che avevamo
nella benzina ne facevamo 05 quindi
vedete che il pensiero piano piano si
sposta si sposta perché si sposta perché
stiamo parlando di due soluzioni
differenti abbiamo detto prima contenuto
e contenitore Adesso invece proviamo a
pensare un attimino Come è fatto il
motore termico che abbiamo utilizzato
noi per tutta la vita il motore termico
è un motore diciamo a benzina così e un
motore che più o meno
dell'energia che noi utilizziamo che noi
mettiamo nel motore termico Circa un
terzo arriva all'alberratore Circa un
terzo va a finire nell'aria e Circa un
terzo invece viene dissipata attraverso
il radiatore un terzo Che cosa vuol dire
facciamo un esempio Supponiamo un'auto
che ha 1000 di cilindrata utilitaria
Quindi a un litro circa sta girando a
circa 3.000 giri benissimo vuol dire che
entra in agire al minuto vuol dire che
in un minuto ha espulso circa 3000 litri
di aria scaldata a 500 600 gradi pensate
in un minuto Ho espulso 3.000 litri
d'aria a 500 gradi un terzo dell'energia
che ho pagato è andata
l'altro terzo mi serve nel radiatore
perché
anche quello è un problema e finalmente
il terzo che resta mi serve per muovermi
e nell'auto elettrica nell'auto
elettrica il motore elettrico è
drammaticamente più efficiente da un
terzo passiamo a circa il 90%, possiamo
anche di più quindi allora batteria
piuttosto che serbatoio contenuto
contenitore poi dopo abbiamo un
trasformatore di energia Diciamo che in
un caso è decisamente poco efficiente
nell'altro caso invece è decisamente
molto efficiente perché il 90% è tanto
Quindi piano piano cominciamo a diciamo
a migliorare la nostra simpatia Secondo
me Verso l'auto elettrica benissimo
C'è un altro punto che su quale Secondo
me vale la pena di riflettere ed è
quello che sostanzialmente il peso
dell'auto perché prima abbiamo detto Ah
ma con un litro di benzina Facciamo 20
km benissimo ma quanto pesa un'auto
un'auto pesa una tonnellata e mezzo
anche qualcosa di più e normalmente cosa
altezza 70 80 kg Beh anche qua Forse si
potrebbe pensare che insomma ci sono
delle soluzioni migliori non voglio
entrare in soluzioni che sono
sicuramente le migliori che sono
mobilità distribuita mezzi pubblici
eccetera perché sono sicuramente
migliori ma non sono compatibili hanno
degli impatti sulla nostra libertà hanno
degli impatti diversi
cambierebbero in maniera differente la
nostra vita soprattutto per noi che
viviamo in posti dove La connettività di
tipo diciamo mezzi pubblici E
decisamente più difficile da realizzare
ma ritorniamo sempre comunque alla
missione vogliamo spostarci da un posto
all'altro vogliamo fare qualche
chilometro abbiamo la nostra auto
peso una tonnellata e mezzo perché pesa
una tonnellata e mezza pesa una
tonnellata e mezza perché vogliamo del
Confort e non ci vogliamo rinunciare
vogliamo che sia bella e non ci vogliamo
rinunciare e poi ci sono tutta una serie
di infrastrutture pesanti intorno
all'auto che ci consentono
sostanzialmente nel caso in cui
dovessimo avere un incidente di uscirne
vivi o quantomeno
diciamo poco malconci Ecco questo
ma anche il discorso legato alla
sicurezza all'incidente di fatto noi
Stiamo caricando la nostra automobile di
dispositivi passivi che ci consentono
nel caso in cui abbiamo un incidente di
migliorare sostanzialmente la nostra
la nostra sicurezza ma l'informazione ci
viene in grande aiuto in questo caso
perché sistemi di sicurezza attivi
migliorano l'auto ci consentono di non
avere l'incidente Quindi anche questo
consente di ridurre qualcosa nell'auto
Ormai già adesso abbiamo tutti
sull'autovettura ce ne saranno sempre di
più e quindi di avere un incidente meno
peso più range
adesso c'è un altro elemento sul quale
vale veramente la pena Secondo me di
riflettere ed è quella
dell'infrastruttura che serve per
l'utilizzo degli auto elettriche Se
guardiamo la potenza ci viene da
piangere perché se pensiamo in auto
Scusate in casa Noi abbiamo normalmente
un contatore da 36 kilowatt kilowatt una
misura di Potenza ma moltiplicati per
un'ora ci danno una misura dell'energia
se vogliamo caricare la nostra batteria
in maniera veloce nella nostra auto
abbiamo bisogno di un centinaio di kW
immaginatevi in un condominio tutti
scendono alle 7 a caricare L'automobile
è finito il gioco Però il problema è un
pochettino diverso Io guido elettrico da
molti anni e le persone mi fanno sempre
la stessa domanda quanta autonomia la
tua auto io ne faccio un'altra che amate
quanta ne serve e pochi mi rispondono
Quante quanti di noi fanno
venerdì diciamo sei giorni alla
settimana 3 km 5.7 10 15 a chi ci
servono 400 500 600 km di autonomia
Questa è la prima domanda da fare quindi
di Quanta energia abbiamo bisogno
l'energia
cominciamo Secondo me a riflettere su
quanto è importante l'energia Perché
Perché
poi lo vedremo ma lo stiamo già vedendo
Secondo me
e c'è un altro un altro punto importante
perché se l'infrastruttura energetica e
un po' il collo di bottiglia dell'auto
elettrica Ma è anche vero che tante auto
con le batterie hanno tanti contenuti di
energia e magari Mentre il mio vicino
vuol solo far tre chilometri Ma il
serbatoio le batterie piene Io le voglio
fare di più e ce lo vuote e magari non
devo neanche attingere
dall'infrastruttura di ricarica ma Posso
semplicemente utilizzare un po' di
energia di quella che lui ha cioè il
parco auto elettriche sicuramente
diventerà una risorsa distribuita di
energia
spostare l'energia elettrica è molto
semplice
richiede dei tempi un pochettino più
lunghi rispetto a spostare delle benzina
ma è decisamente molto semplice ma
questo che cosa comporta comporta la
l'importanza dell'infrastruttura
informatica perché perché vuol dire che
tutti dobbiamo essere collegati vuol
dire che il mio vicino deve mettere e
questo possiamo discutere sulla libertà
se vogliamo ma forse un'altra
discussione che probabilmente avrebbe la
pena di fare ma tanto tutti sappiamo che
tutti sanno tutto di noi e il nostro
vicino vorrebbe andare da qualche parte
se l'infrastruttura informatica sa dove
deve andare sa di Quanta energia ha
bisogno io posso avvicinarmi troveremo
delle soluzioni ne sono sicuro
tirargli via un po' di energia dalla sua
batteria trovare il modo di pagargliela
in qualche modo ma questo permette
sostanzialmente di ridurre in maniera
drammatica le infrastruttura quindi
magari tanta dell'energia che noi stiamo
spostando e quindi da impianti che
faranno l'energia e questo è un altro
tema come la faremo l'energia elettrica
Ma è un tema di un'altra discussione
anche probabilmente non con me anche i
come la vogliamo utilizzare come ce la
vogliamo spartire come come può essere
anche se vogliamo una sorgente
Democratica l'energia
una persona non voglio fare giudizi di
nessun tipo però
Barack Obama ha detto in tempi quasi non
sospetti che una nazione che non può
controllare le sue fonti di energia non
può controllare il suo futuro penso che
sappiamo in questo periodo lo sappiamo
molto molto bene Penso che l'energia di
fatto è qualche cosa di davvero molto
importante nella nostra vita e quindi
come ci spostiamo Quanta energia
utilizziamo come utilizziamo l'energia
Io penso che sia qualche cosa su cui
valga la pena di riflettere Perché
Perché
l'energia Ha un impatto ha un costo e
noi conosciamo il costo diciamo
economico
spesso non consideriamo il costo sociale
non consideriamo neanche l'impatto
ambientale che all'utilizzo dell'energia
e buttarla via abbiamo visto il 30% Che
buttiamo nel nell'atmosfera quando
accendiamo l'auto e non è una gran cosa
Quindi dobbiamo veramente Secondo me
fare delle riflessioni sull'utilizzo
dell'energia
A questo punto se l'energia è così
costosa E ha dei costi così importanti e
con i costi non considero i due euro al
litro o due cinque che diventeranno ma
dei costi davvero più importante siamo
davvero sicuri che la benzina costa
troppo
qui finisce la mia chiacchierata
[Musica]